the same habits that make students
illiberal that make them oppose freedom
of speech are the same mental habits
that make people anxious and depressed
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine and this
is a show for you if you want honest
conversations with fascinating people
our brilliant guest today is the
president of fire the foundation for
individual rights and education and the
co-author of the coddling of the
american mind greg lieutenant welcome to
trigonometry yeah thanks for having me
it's a great pleasure to have you on the
show i've given you the full
introduction there but tell us a little
bit about the story behind that how are
you who are you how are you where you
are what has been your journey through
life that leads you to be sitting here
talking to us
oh wow okay so we were talking a little
bit before the camera started rolling
about my family history um i'm a first
generation american my father is russian
by way of yugoslavia and my mother is
irish by way of england um and because
of the peculiarities of each culture my
ethically irish mother thinks of herself
as british and my ethnically russian
father thinks himself as russian because
you don't just wake up one morning and
decide you're serbian like that's just
not the way identity works um in that
part of the world
um so i i grew up uh you know we were
pretty uh broke slash poor when i when i
was a kid i grew up in a neighborhood
with lots of other kids
um from you know peru from vietnam from
korea from the dominican republic from
puerto rico
um and the the white kids in my
neighborhood were actually from the
american south which is a first
generation american seemed even stranger
and more exotic to me um
and so i had the sort of first
generation
american slash immigrant kind of
appreciation for american freedom of
speech because we know how
uh
how rare that is historically and and
how unusual america's commitment to to
to that is um both historically and in
the world uh particularly at the moment
um so i went to undergrad um which was
kind of a surprise i wasn't really
totally sure i was going to go to
college at all i studied
journalism and international relations
thinking i would you know do some
following my father's footsteps who
speak seven languages
but as a journalism um a double major i
got to see you know with my own eyes how
people will come into your office all
the time
will come into the newspaper the student
newspaper office and demand that the you
the editor fire somebody because of what
they published or with withdraw that
article and it really started to become
clear to me that like people are
natural-born sensors like they want to
figure out a way to punish you for
saying that article and they're still
rationalizing that they completely
believe in freedom of speech but the
wheels start turning um and they're like
i think you should punish this person
for what's the magic word at the moment
i felt threatened i felt intimidated i
felt harassed
um and and finally the final link in the
chain for free speech was the
communications decency act was passed um
in 1995 um and this was the old version
of it that actually tried to ban
indecency that's the word of it on the
internet uh back in 1995 and that's
laughably unconstitutional under the
american first amendment um and that's
what made me decide to go to law school
i went to uh stanford for law school i
took every class that they they offered
on on first amendment when i ran out i
did six credits on censorship during the
tudor dynasty
because it was this was like my lifelong
passion um and everybody thought a
little nuts for hyper focusing on this
thing that there weren't many jobs in
but my superpower is when fire found me
out in san francisco you know pay
offering me fifty thousand dollars a
year you know given my life history was
kind of like wow this is amazing i could
do a huge amount of money for for
graduate
um and so i worked there you know from i
was the legal director from 2001 to
2005. i became the president 2005 and
officially interim and then became
president in 2006. um and then i was
lucky enough to have a complete mental
breakdown because the culture was so
incredibly depressing and so alienating
and so difficult to fight all the time
the good news is about that suicidal
depression is it led me to start doing
um cognitive behavioral therapy uh which
created the basis for my my work with
jonathan height my good friend um lovely
person by the way um uh
i i wrote an article with him in 2015
called coddling the american mind by the
way a title i have never liked and and
i've fought pretty much at every stage
because i think it alienates the very
people who need to read it
so we did the article um in 2015 about
like how the same habits that make
students illiberal that make them oppose
freedom of speech are the same mental
habits that make people anxious and
depressed and so we wrote this in the
summer 2015 and we fixed the whole thing
well quite i mean you you it's it's a
very funny joke but i that was actually
the question that i was going to go to
because i said to you before we started
myself
francis our whole team we were all
incredibly
uh impressed and persuaded and informed
and
interested in what you and jonathan
wrote
in the coddling of the american mind uh
how do you see some of those dynamics
that you've mentioned
playing out in recent years particularly
in the last few years where are we with
that culture war that gave you the
breakdown in the first place yeah is it
time for another one is what i'm asking
oh yeah believe me don't don't don't
encourage me i've been feeling a little
bit that way lately um the but just you
know for your listeners
one of the reasons why i'm such a
proponent of cognitive behavioral
therapy is i used to struggle with
depression pretty severely
as i got older pretty much every year
and you know with the help of i'm
lightly medicated but so
no nothing against medicine um but the
big difference was cbt and eventually
you know the depressive voices in your
head just don't sound as convincing
anymore which it takes a long time it
takes a lot of work but but it really
does happen anyway so 2015 happened um
there was a summer in 2015. little did
we know that the fall of 2015 would be a
terrible uh a terrible year that's when
i um i was the one who videotaped the
students surrounding my friend nicholas
christakis at yale you know telling him
that it was horrible because his wife
wrote something saying that should we
really be policing the halloween costume
choices of the students and this
happened all there were there were about
a hundred of these kind of incidents
where it was something relatively minor
and then next thing you knew activists
were demanding that
for example umass amherst um that the
student newspaper uh stopped being
funded you know that mary spellman at
claremont mckenna get fired for example
so 2015 was pretty bad um and
2017 even scarier that's when you had
the berkeley riots that's when you had
um
you had the assault on allison stenger
protecting charles murray at middlebury
so 2017 was really bad um and that's one
of the reasons why we decided to write
the book coddling the american mind
which came out in 2018
and we were hoping that it was as bad as
it was going to get but we had a feeling
it was going to get worse we didn't know
how much worse and how soon because 2020
was without exception
the worst year for freedom of speech
and academic freedom i have seen in my
entire career the second worst year 2021
um and so it's been a very disheartening
um couple of years
it's kind of funny because there are
still people who will talk about like
cancel culture isn't real and it's like
and and literally like after the new
york times finally you know wrote an
editorial saying well actually
everything indicates it's real including
our own polling and you know people on
twitter it blew their minds they they
completely freaked out and including
people saying give me one example of
someone
and it's like i have a database and this
is just professors of
now we're getting close to 600
professors who were targeted for for
being cancelled since 2015. about
two-thirds of them happened just since
2020. um about one-fifth of them were
fired about uh
also about you know about three-fifths
of them were punished in some way um
whether that's you know loss of position
or or whatever this includes 30 ten-year
professors who were fired for their for
their expression or for their pedagogy
or for their research that's the only
reason why tenure exists and generally
like tenured professors could have been
fired in the past when i first started
my career but that was for like
murdering somebody or like or not
showing up the class or just like
genuinely like leaving the country doing
something illegal or just failing to do
your job entirely um them being fired
for um
for their uh point of view for for their
expression that's the whole reason why
tenured exists in the first place so and
that's just professors the the number of
students um who who get in trouble is
many times that and we're and that's
harder to dig up because when a student
gets expelled that doesn't make the the
student newspaper for example
um so uh it has been the worst couple of
years of my career and my big fear is
that just the same way you had sort of
like the political correctness thing of
the late 80s
um and early 90s uh that kind of passed
after a while after the speech codes
were defeated in court after comedians
started making fun of it it kind of fell
out of fashion and people kind of went
thank god that's over but then from 1995
to 2015 things just got worse but just
more quietly with less attention and i
what and i can feel that there's a
little bit of a sense that people are
returning to their sanity on some of
this stuff but if we don't but if we
just go oh thank goodness that's over
again the next time the pendulum swings
which will be sooner it's going to be
even worse still
so greg thank you for making me
depressed now
i'm here we can get you some cbt
but greg in your book
there were lots you pointed out lots of
reasons why this was the case yep
which do you think are the most
important ones
why we find ourselves in this position
now
you know my two are the two we started
with um in in the uh we talk about seven
causal threads in calling the american
mind because of course we do you know we
have to make it as complicated as
possible actually sorry we talked about
six but we added a seventh later but the
two most important ones to me are
um social media is what sped these
these trends up um a lot of these things
were existed already um you know like
the
um
the sort of what what what's the best
word for it like revivication of um of
uh ad hominem arguments uh that
essentially the the idea that you would
focus on the person not the argument
they're making was something that at
minimum college was supposed to be
teaching people to you know that
actually that's kind of disfavored but
just because someone's horrible doesn't
mean they're wrong and just because
someone's a saint doesn't mean they're
right this is just logical this is just
also true
um so
i think when social media came along it
came at a confluence of
uh higher ed you know adopting these uh
one kind of giving up to a surprising
degree on on the on the rules of
argumentation but also on on the even
more pernicious side uh k-12 and college
teaching that ad hominem arguments are
essentially good
that essentially yes you know like this
is a this is a life is a battle between
good people and evil people is what we
call our third great untruth i'm in the
book basically the untruths are the idea
of it's as if we're giving the words the
world's worst possible advice to a
generation of students and we call that
the great untruth of polarization so i
do think that that um the confluence of
social media um a bunch of bad things
are happening in k-12 a bunch of bad
things are happening in higher ed
added to polarization and by by that i
also mean
the big sort theory um which is you know
also plays out that literally americans
of different um who vote for different
candidates and who come from economic
different economic classes don't even
interact with that
with with each other all that much
anymore so i think that this it's very
easy to start seeing people who disagree
with you
um as evil um if you don't know any of
those any of those people to think that
they're stupid or evil which is one of
the reasons why lack of viewpoint
diversity on campus was a much more
serious problem than people understood
going back to the 80s because it's when
you have this kind of situation where
you know basically you have a coherent
moral community of overwhelmingly people
who who are more left-leaning
uh the dynamics around your appreciation
for free speech shifts because free
speech is the argument of uh
so i always have to
forgive me from going on too long but
talking about um uh
the rich and the powerful have always
been fine historically with a couple
exceptions of course um but uh in a
democracy if you have 50
or more uh you you get to make the rules
and it really the only people who
benefit from a separate idea of the of
free speech or for that matter the first
amendment under the under those
circumstances are people who are in
minority point of view or who have
unpopular beliefs with
with with elites when you go from being
you know uh
roughly two to one conservative to
uh
liberal to conservative
um on on campus to five to one or thirty
to one in some departments with with
with a overwhelming majority when it
comes to administrators more like 95 you
know 95 percent
um
it's predictable that you start seeing
free speech is not something that's your
ally you start seeing is something that
of more of a of an inconvenience
i i still can't get my head around why
people would think that free speech is
more of an inconvenience
how have we got to this point where we
take something so fundamental to our
society and treat it so frivolously
i i think it's it to a degree it's
regression to the mean um
that uh that essentially most of human
history is about um censorship you know
that essentially the sensors generally
one
there's a reason why i call my blog the
eternally radical idea because the idea
that everyone's entitled their opinion
and that the fact of that opinion um
their right to hold that opinion is is
absolutely their right um even if you
think they might be wrong
um is a very radical idea and you know
this because in every generation people
stand up
to oppose it um we like to always point
out these freedom fighters in history
and it's like well who are they fighting
against um and it's most of human
history that the other side the forces
of conformity the forces of authority
the forces of group think the forces of
religion all of these things um
they all conspire against freedom of
speech
and so freedom of speech has to be
taught it has to be valued and one of
the ways you see what a culture values
is in their idioms um like the little
sayings that they have that pepper their
speech and so growing up in in in the us
you always heard it's a free country
everyone's entitled to their own opinion
to each his own or
her own walk a mile in a man's shoes and
for that matter even none of your
business you know um these were all
these are all kind of ideas that uh
undergird a democratic society um but
those have increasingly fallen away
um and i think in no small part because
we disproportionately and i think to a
degree that is unhealthy we we rely in
the united states on a ruling class that
sound very marxist about it that comes
overwhelmingly from a hand through a
handful of colleges i know partially
because i went to one of them um and it
and when you actually start having
you know a um
a democracy you know
choosing its leaders only from a
relatively narrow you know batch of
schools that already see free speech as
an impediment to their agenda you
shouldn't be surprised that this starts
um coming down uh it's starting to seem
like what most americans think now on
polling this is absolutely not what most
americans think but uh if your
impression of what the country looks
like is twitter which you know the two
percent of the two percent dominate um
then yeah i mean it it can really start
to feel that free speech is this this
neanderthal idea and we're finally
coming around to enlighten censorship
and i always have to be the person
reminding them that enlightened
censorship or people who think they're
engaging lightnings
is the rule of human history not the
exception
and and the thing that really blew my
mind was from a couple of months ago
where the u.s government were advocating
censorship of podcasts in particular joe
rogan yeah and i'm and i was watching
that going is this really america is
this really the land of the free is this
really
what i i would associate with america
no well did the whole disinformation
thing is um
i get it i i understand how it that
disinformation can be used by your
enemies it can be used by malicious
people it can be used by snake oil
salesmen um to profit or to disrupt or
or
or whatever
but it is the reason why it's so hard to
fight is because the other option is
omniscience
you know like that essentially we that's
one of the reasons why free speech works
so well is because in the grand scheme
of things we're all incredibly
self-deluded animals like we we we are
very bad at guessing what the truth is
we're very bad at knowing um if the
person talking talking to us is a liar
we're overconfident in our current
beliefs we're overconfident that our age
has all of the moral questions
uh settled um and uh free speech is this
constant recognition of epistemic
humility that in the grand scheme of
things we don't we don't know all that
much stuff so when it's amazing to me
when people point out yeah
disinformation is a problem and it's one
that has to be combated but the way you
combat it is by having experts that
people generally trust
um talking about these things and
treating people like adults when you
start having a situation where people
think that higher education journalism
experts in general are biased in some
way
and that that trust starts to be
undermined that's a very dangerous thing
for for a democratic society i also
think by the way social media makes that
process inevitable and we have to figure
out how to live
with that disruption but you can censor
by going after disinformation you you
can uh by claiming to go after
disinformation you can censor
practically everybody
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy dns is a company for you easy dns
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be cancel culture d
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so we'll you in a second easy dns have
rock-solid network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns right now all you've got to do
is go to easydns.com
forward slash triggered that's
easydns.com
forward slash triggered use our promo
code which is also triggered and get
fifty percent off the initial purchase
sign up for their newsletter access of
easy which tells you everything you need
to know about technology privacy and
censorship
and greg this i'm really glad you bring
up the point about social media from
that perspective because god knows i'm
on your side and i agree with you and
free speech is great and you know the
one of the points that we've explored
extensively here on trigonometry from
the beginning is how important it is and
with you know both of our backgrounds we
understand its value
but in the context of elon musk's
attempted purchase of twitter recently
uh there was a thread i don't know if
you saw it from a guy called yeshang
wong i think is is his name
he's he used to run reddit and one of
the points that he made he was like look
guys i was there in the early days of
the internet i'm all for free speech but
the internet we have now which is
dominated by social media any large
network of communication will will not
be able to provide the free speech quote
unquote that we all want because uh in
the end large numbers of people arguing
about stuff whether that's baking
cookies or whether that's politics
results in tribalism results in
confrontation it results in bias results
in people trying to censor each other
and all of that and eventually the
network has to step in not because they
are trying to lock down our ability to
speak but because some of the behavior
that is being exhibited in the real
world as a result of of that that speech
is harmful yeah now i am very much just
just to finish this someone who leans
even to the into the point like look
some speech is harmful but it's still
better for people to be able to speak
but what do you say broadly to this idea
that we live in a social media world in
which censorship is inevitable and
actual free speech in the way that you'd
think about it 200 years ago uh at the
founding of the united states is just
not possible anymore yeah i would think
that um the person making that argument
doesn't understand how sophisticated for
example first amendment jurisprudence is
um i i describe american first amendment
jurisprudence you know about as about
100 years of the best and brightest
people in the united states figuring out
how you have freedom of speech in the
real world um you know warts and all how
and how you try to minimize some of the
consequences how you actually draw and
that's one of the reasons why when elon
musk was talking about this i took it as
an opportunity to write an open letter
you know to elon musk saying hey
you know actually why don't you try to
um uh peg your norms towards an existing
body of
of thought that actually is very
practical
um
and and one of the things that i you
know so
i i think um what was it what was the
name of the one that got shut down
parlor uh pauline yeah parlor and parlor
when it got shut down i didn't know
enough about the site to have a strong
opinion on it but the accusation was
that people were conspiring to commit
actual crimes and of course that's not
protected um threats of bodily harm or
death are not protected um i mean one of
the things that immediately um
required some amount of moderation on
the internet you know going back to its
earliest days is spam you know people
just
would they'd be spammed to death if
there wasn't some amount of moderation
but i do think that there are sensible
principles that you can draw from it um
which are like that nobody should be
punished simply for expressing their
opinion that essentially you can't have
viewpoint discrimination on a topic um
when you have a social media a social
media platform you can have general
parameters you can even it's even
acceptable within within first amendment
norms which is of course very strong
that you could have um what would be
called a limited public forum like on
this one we're just talking about buffy
the vampire slayer you know uh for for
example
i think that um
it's not as hard as people think to do
some of this you know you know not
punishing people on the basis of
viewpoint is a good start um you can
have viewpoint neutral rules um in place
anyway but the thing that i wanted to
sort of raise the discussion a little
bit
in talking to elon you know with the
idea of elon musk taking this over
is uh
just to go back to someone who's
influenced my thought a lot since
codling came out um at uh
martin guri he wrote a book called
revolt of the public
and my way of interpreting what he's
saying
is that social media proved itself
capable of tearing down any person any
institution or any idea
and this is actually not the worst thing
in some cases i mean hosni mubarak in
egypt it's good you know that he got
torn down there are lots of regimes that
needed to be torn down there needed to
be more light shined on abusive police
practices in the us
for example but it's utterly incapable
of building at this point that
essentially if you want to tear
something down social media is great if
you want to actually build something
constructive it will not help you it'll
probably actually
completely sabotage that but we
shouldn't give up on the idea that we
can get something much more productive
um for the produce and this is where i'm
going to sound very pie in the sky
production of human knowledge from
social media why
because the great institution of
disconfirmation you know which is either
the republic of letters or what higher
education is supposed to be um is all
about disconfirmation um just as
confirmation within some rules that ad
hominems don't count again like i said
you can be you can be right and be a
horrible person
um and so i do think that if you could
think of a way to use social media that
rather than um completely banking on the
uh on the outrage machine um tried to
actually use it to you know more
thoughtful um uh more well-structured
arguments actually get more
more discussion there i i believe that
there's a way to do it that we could
have it go from something that is just
snarky gossip to something that might
actually have a
positive benefit on the species well
you're right that does sound pie in the
sky um
but but look
as i say i'm playing devil's advocate
and i'm fully on on your side of the
argument
but at the same time
you know the argument for example like
look take the hunter biden story that
was suppressed by the the by uh social
media and take the banning of donald
trump from twitter my take on that is
that to me those two events are
essentially they are
i don't want to sound extreme but to me
that was the end of democracy in a way
if you can't get accurate information
and if you can ban the sitting president
of the united states from speaking on on
the biggest public platform that there
is yeah you know you've ended our
ability to make decisions independently
based on the information that we want to
seek out however the argument would be
from the people who are involved in that
censorship is well that is a point where
free speech causes real world harm and
it becomes equivalent of screaming fire
in a theater now given now i don't agree
with that point even with january the
sixth and all of that but
the they could have been the
interpretation certainly from the social
media companies that that is what was
happening their platforms were being
used to organize i mean they call it an
insurrection call it whatever you want a
large-scale riot in the heart of the
world's greatest democracy right i live
on capitol hill by the way so like right
so we were in the group
isn't that
inevitably where we're always going to
end up it's always going to be at that
extreme where yeah you can have your
free speech and use the network
responsibly but at the end of the day
when push comes to shove when it's
crunch time someone is going to get on
twitter and go this election was bs
let's all get to x place and start y
action
yeah i mean i i think that these are
there are going to be you know misfires
and mistakes inevitably in any system um
you impose but there's there's a
difference between trying to maximize
freedom of speech and freedom of opinion
um and giving up on the whole thing
because the system fails sometimes and
when it comes to the hunter biden thing
um you know i
am somewhat with my my friend john roush
like like the idea of being a little bit
spooked about the idea of there being
you know russian disinformation about
this sounding because it sounded fishy
frankly like the idea of like they found
a laptop at a company like suddenly
right around the time of the election
um still i think uh twitter made
absolutely the wrong call um but i'm not
saying it's as crazy
as it sounds under the under the
circumstances and when it comes to um
you know january 6 that the the standard
in the law is is the incitement standard
under brandenburg there are first
amendment lawyers you know saying
this may not be exactly brandenburg but
it's damn close and there are other
people like david french who actually
thought it thought across the line for
example into even a violation of first
amendment standards so i i think that
the some of these issues are not
necessarily as hard as they sound um
and they don't devalue the entire system
well
greg what you're saying to me sounds
even harder than what i thought it was
because
you can have your lawyers adjudicating
on it for years to come but that
decision has to be made in the moment by
twitter so what was the right decision
in that situation in your opinion
i try to be non-partisan um
in my take on it but i am a democrat um
you know which i
explained to the genuine horror of trump
people
um
they're so nasty i mean honestly like i
think under the circumstances
saying that it was close enough to
incitement not necessarily the legal
standard that they they could say he
shouldn't be included and i know i'm
gonna get a lot of hate mail for that so
thanks probably so are we but that's why
we bring people on because we want to
hear what they actually think what about
hunter biden i mean well that that's
this is where the problem is greg let me
just make this point quick
the problem i have with all of this is
you can have your brilliant standards
and you can go look a sitting president
shouldn't be able to incite people to go
and protest about something that is
likely to spill over okay let's say i
agree with you the problem is something
like the hunter biden story do you think
if donald trump jr had handed his laptop
into some repair shop
and it turned out there was whatever i
don't want to get you know sued for
libel but some kind of pawn some kind of
evidence of drug taking some kind of
evidence of corruption do you think
twitter would have suppressed that story
from being shared absolutely not and
that's and that's the reason why
and and to be clear for hunter biden
that was a mistake in my opinion i'm
just making the point that it's not um
that that was a bad call and it was
wrong and i protested at the time and
and i still do
um the uh
the my only point with the john roush
point was that it might not be as
arbitrary as as it might have seen at
the time because like i said it sounded
it sounded kind of fishy i would hope
that any journalist hearing an
implausible sounding backstory would be
kind of like
that is that really true but nonetheless
what they did the laptop thing was a
mistake that they should be embarrassed
and ashamed
of greg isn't the problem that what
we've got is of these companies which
are huge
conglomerates they're privately owned
and as a result they're going to do like
all corporations do and act in their own
self-interest
and that being the case they cannot be
trusted with these hugely powerful tools
and be the ones in charge of
disseminating information to the public
yeah let's give it to the government
yeah exactly you know that that's my
answer to that
is that essentially people think that
and and this is one of the funny things
like as far as like a i'm not like a
full libertarian but i'm definitely a
civil libertarian but the most useful
contribution like the term that i
borrowed from libertarianism um and i
just added naive to it which is naive
statism that essentially the fix to
everything is just hand it over to the
government and they will do it way way
better i and i and i'd really rather
have something you know driven by the
profit motive um than by driven by pure
political calculation
unfortunately by having a lack of
viewpoint diversity in silicon valley
you end up with situations where there
wasn't someone you know at twitter to be
like whoa whoa whoa whoa um we're
we're taking away the new york freaking
posts
um
twitter access for like a couple of days
over a story that might be true
um
so i do think that that the existing
silicon valley um has a major problem in
that it has doesn't have sufficient
viewpoint diversity among itself still i
when it comes to a lot of the solutions
i find the solutions worth worth worse
than the disease i i think people would
be scared like so i always found it
really kind of like jaw-dropping that
republicans were always talking about
how
you know uh and trump in particular was
talking about dropping uh the existing
version of section 230 um which
which protects um uh social media giants
from from liability in a number of cases
because if they weren't protected from
that the very first people they would
drop would be overwhelmingly
conservative now to be clear i don't
think there is a perfect solution to uh
to any of this i do occasionally think
that sometimes the the companies as much
as maligned as they are made some
actually pretty good calls i was
originally very skeptical of the
facebook um
like uh overseer board thing uh because
i assumed what would happen is they
would since they were trying to make it
international that it would turn into
the convoy system and the least speech
protective person in in the board would
actually be
the one who you know decides but setting
up an outside body um what uh was was
actually a pretty good call so i think
that there are ways to navigate it and
what i'm more scared of is that people
are gonna think that well you know the
whole problem is social media um is
corrupt so therefore we're gonna come up
with a solution that actually ends up
throwing out the baby with the bass
bathwater but but but let's talk about
power greg because power is at the root
of all this and that these companies are
so powerful they can effectively do what
they want
even if it means silencing the president
of the united states even if it means
influencing elections
and nothing happens to them
you know like you said hunter biden was
a bad call and i know we're coming off
as massive trump is here which we're
actually not we're just exploring the
the edge of the argument right it's like
hunter biden was an awful decision in my
opinion just i chose this yep but
where's where's the you know where's the
pushback where's the punishment this is
to me that's a really serious crime
because if i was running that company
i'll be honestly i'd be like oh hey we
may have changed the course of an
election nothing happened
mm-hmm you know look at this magic ring
i'm wearing now so i i i i understand
this but my point is not that they don't
do things wrong and that there are
abuses that can be um uh
better handled but like what what is the
solution then like because most of what
i'm saying what i've been saying about
this is that i'm more afraid of the
solution than than the disease what do
you think would actually fix it
okay so
would you be in favor for instance of
again government entering and breaking
it up like they would do with monopolies
because it can be argued that these
companies are monopolies
yeah i've heard about that one um i
possibly um when it comes to uh you know
breaking up um monopolies i i do
actually think that trust busting
sometimes can sometimes can help but i
know i know a lot of my libertarian
friends would say actually it didn't
achieve anything i don't know like i
remember when a t you know owned
everything and i definitely feel like
there was a big telecom explosion after
they were broken up um so maybe yeah
i think we're probably approaching this
the wrong way greg
you don't think there is a solution do
you no
why um because nothing in life is that
simple
right well that that is something that
resonates with me very strongly so
so what do we do then because at the end
of the day we can you the three of us
can sit here and go there is no solution
but we still have to do something right
oh yeah you know
i i think we should experiment i think
we should try a variety of different
experiments and this is the way the way
i end up putting it
um is that
a lot of times when people look at like
mayan heights take on social media and
how we point out all the downsides of it
i actually always tried to try to like
chime in when we were writing saying by
the way i actually i have a lovely
experience on most of social media there
are positive there are genuinely uh
positive things about it but when people
hear how critical we are of some aspects
of it and we absolutely are and i still
very much am and particularly the weight
i think it drives our entire political
class kind of insane um
i think it's actually very unhealthy
that so many of the nation's journalists
are are are on twitter
but people will point out it's like oh
haydn lukianov they probably said this
would say the same thing about the
printing press and i'm always like
you mean the technology that led to a
massive increase in the witch trials
that led to about 200 years of religious
uh of religious wars in europe like that
it was
the defining disruptive technology um it
had over overall was it worth it yes um
was it peaceful god no i mean it was
incredibly powerful so what i feel like
we're doing right now
is where it's like i don't know 14
98 and we're looking at the at the
printing press and saying to ourselves
um what's the easy fix that's going to
get us out of this situation and the
answer is there isn't one um and because
that was adding millions of people to
the discussion it was probably adding
thousands of people it like
of additional publishers or tens of
thousands additional publishers but
making people you know
making millions of recipients
information now we have a two-way
conversation with billions of people
that is that is unprecedented in human
history there is no way this isn't going
to be highly disruptive um there's no
way it isn't going to um come with all
sorts of new problems um so what i would
hope for would be that when we're doing
solutions and this is one thing in terms
of like a way to think about the way we
come up with solutions is uh like they
say with medication for uh for um
for all sorts of reasons um you know go
uh uh go slow and start low um then
essentially try a variety of different
fixes give them credit where they
actually do seem to be helping i i for
example think twitter was helped out a
lot by the fact that they doubled the um
uh the character limit you know uh
several years ago i think that actually
improved the level of discourse i live
in a in what i consider to be a kind of
nice bubble on twitter where i follow a
lot of my expert friends we have
relatively civil conversations i so i do
think that that that um
uh my fear is that the absolute worst of
what goes on in social media could uh be
used and that could stifle the best of
what comes out social media which i do
think is a real thing
i'm really glad you bring up the
printing press because i do think that's
a really really useful
analogy here
um and but i think underlying both the
printing press and social media is
something that's very obvious
out of all of this which is that ideas
are very powerful things
and so if we're talking about free
speech
in a world where
i can tweet something
and
be part of a thing on social media that
starts a civil war somewhere which is
probably where we are already if we're
not heading there
um
[Music]
isn't that isn't it inevitable that that
is you know it's just too powerful not
to be censored by somebody isn't it
well even within um
first amendment law it's kind of funny
because a lot of times people who don't
know a lot about
american first amendment law will talk
about the great european um sort of
balancing of interests that they try to
do that essentially free speech is just
one among multiple different interests
um in in other bodies of law i think
personally that's why it's a disaster in
many of the countries in europe it that
they do this ad-hoc balancing and free
speech is always on the losing side but
believe it or not american freedom of
speech even in terms of the law is a
balancing act it's just considered to be
a balancing act with a very heavy thumb
on the on the scale and the balancing is
called strict scrutiny um i i i
sometimes i remember actually kind of
horrifying um a friend of mine by not
being uh like she actually did you guys
watch the battlestar galactica um like
the one that was on
the reboot
yeah and i love that show um but uh it's
about you know a planet of 10 billion
people uh 50 000 people are left
um and there's this constant battle
about whether or not they're maintained
democracy on the ship and i'm kind of
like okay i will say that and there's
there's spaceships following them trying
to completely complete the genocide and
i'm like okay
even american law understands that the
rules are a little different when you're
like this close to oblivion
when you're this close so i do think
that that there's a there's a level of
sophistication within the law that says
you know like for example like the
pentagon papers um they talk about the
idea of printing the time and place of
transport ships being sent out you know
um and that's and at least nominally
within the law that's like yeah there
are actually levels at which you you can
censor even factual information however
i i have a hard time thinking of of a
single situation where simply someone's
honest expression of opinion would
actually end the world
expression of opinion yes but
the the difficulty is that a continued
expression of a certain opinion over
time
is pretty much what led to trump being
taken off twitter isn't it
i thought that was specifically what
happened on january 6 though
but
i mean i think the argument would be
that what happened on january 6th is a
product of his communication on twitter
over time
you know calling the election into
question
and all of that isn't wouldn't that be
the argument so i guess my point is all
i'm say all i'm asking you is is it not
inevitable that social media will be a
place where at the end of the day
someone goes well we've reached
battlestar galactica point now like this
is real now this is real world [ __ ] and
if we don't shut this down someone's
gonna get her or a thousand people are
gonna get hurt or the country's gonna go
to to whatever and so we're always gonna
end up in a position where we don't
actually have freedom of speech online
in that way because it's just too
powerful now because the multiplication
of you know me saying something at home
uh to my wife or us chatting here is
very different to me saying that very
same thing on twitter
yeah i mean
i i think about times where freedom of
speech in the us like uh
took a turn for the worse and i think of
like the um
the red scare like the the den uh the
dennis case in 1951. and i always try to
give like extra context it's like so
american spies and british spies gave
super hitler stalin
the the h-bomb um and so i always i was
trying to put that in there to be kind
of like people had a reason to be
spooked but i still think that the law
went in the wrong direction uh briefly
in the 1950s saying that people who were
just members of the communist party
could be uh thrown in jail
um was that the wrong call yes did
freedom of speech die that day in the
united states no
that's an interesting point why didn't
you think it died that day then
because it it because history kept going
because
later decisions they found that uh they
they tried there was there was an
attempt sort of like to pull to um
withdraw from the free speech purism
that that was developing after 1925. uh
so you have the bohanese case for
example that talked about um that you
can't defame people on the basis of race
that was basically like and that was
found to be
basically an early version of hate
speech laws was found to be
constitutional in the us in the early
1950s but that none of those cases have
ever been replicated since and that the
law kept on progressing we look back
with some disappointment or some horror
about what we did several years ago but
free speech didn't die because we didn't
give up on it um and you and yeah there
are gonna
mistakes are going to be made that is
inevitable under literally every single
system um that you develop but as soon
as we do the thing where it's like well
i guess that didn't work in that case so
let's just give up on free speech
entirely um that's how you actually turn
your sense of doom into a
self-fulfilling prophecy of actual doom
hey kkk do you like podcasts no in
russia we don't have podcast all we need
are beautiful and true words of uncle
vlad to guide us and how's that working
out not good but still more trustworthy
than bbc sky cnn fox news and msnbc good
point but for those of you who do like a
funny and informative podcast then
you've got to check out the girlfriend
translator the two co-hosts to women
they'll answer all your questions why
ask women questions uncomflex as women
are only four because it gives men
objective advice on the minefield that
is dating and relationships in 2022 if
you're wondering why she never called
you back why she lost interest or simply
how to become a better partner then you
have to check this show out she didn't
call you back because you're not real
man you don't write bear with shot off
okay mate uh but it's not just for men
ladies you can listen and find out what
makes men tick and an insight into male
psychology there's only one answer to
that
plus it's funny and you get to ask the
host questions if you've ever had a
situation in a relationship that has
left you feeling confused and want an
impartial point of view then you need to
check out the girlfriend translator
check out girlfriend translator wherever
you get your podcast i've never listened
to it because it is appropriately banned
in russia
greg let's move on now when we were
talking at the very start of the
interview we were talking about
education we were talking about college
education
and it seems to me the the victim and
all of this there are many victims
but
possibly the biggest victims are kids
and college kids themselves because
they're not being taught how to think
they're not being taught
how to debate they're not being taught
to listen they're not being taught how
to develop as people
what is that doing not only to that
generation but to the individual
themselves
oh man yeah i mean my first book was
called unlearning liberty
and the idea was that i felt like people
were going into higher education in
particular and coming out hostile to a
lot of democratic uh small d democratic
norms um when it comes to the mental
health aspect of it i think it's even
worse because
and this is where like i usually try to
keep my cool um but as far as something
that actually just makes me flat out
angry
is you know when coddling came out we
still had people saying um
uh the evidence just isn't there that
there's a mental health crisis on on on
campus
um and that and in 2015 when we wrote
the initial article that you know the
the the research wasn't out yet um
literally but we were saying we were
hearing of this on campus um and then
when the numbers finally came out it was
way way worse than we thought
um so we wrote the book basically saying
it's as if we are giving a generation of
students the kind of advice that will
make them anxious and depressed
um we know this for a fact now that the
kids are hitting higher education with
way higher rates of depression anxiety
mood disorders self-harm and suicide
even among like 10 to 14 year olds which
is like pains me to like talk about like
like the the fact that you're talking
about
uh a big spike in suicide rates for
people that that young
so to know that for a fact and still
teach students
to basically effectively whisper in
their ears by the way you can't really
handle hearing things um that are
offensive to you you will be permanently
damaged by it you won't recover um and
by the way um most of you the
overwhelming majority of you are both
oppressors and depressed there's not
very much you can do about it other than
feel bad and apologetic about yourself
um and you know again and you're not
very resilient um and life is
essentially you know
everybody out you know your parents are
essentially evil and your other
americans are out to get you and
everyone's secretly against you if
they're not nominally against you it's
like that is a messed up thing to tell
anyone but when you know that they're
coming in with high rates of suicide
anxiety and depression
that's just not acceptable by any
stretch of the imagination so so i've
definitely
i i think a lot about ways to get out of
the educational system we have in the us
in
in in radical steps like because k-12
um it's kind of weird because like the
public education system in in
in america has its problems but some of
the worst ideologies coming out of the
most elite you know prep schools
and meanwhile higher education i mean
even just on cost and bureaucratization
alone it's it's insane like the idea
that someone at sarah lawrence can say
with a straight face
that it's 70 000 a year
and that covers only half the cost of
educating a single student for a single
year and they really will say this and
it's like that's nuts that's a failure
of the system if you're saying that you
can't educate a single student for less
than a hundred and forty thousand
dollars a year that's just
that's just completely crazy so there
are lots of uh when i think about you
know what we need to do
with regards to higher education i i
think every and all experiment
should be acceptable and i don't think
we should be massively subsidizing
um
over-bureaucratized incredibly expensive
um country clubs
yeah um
we've had many people on the show you
know former professors or current
professors
and there's a consensus among many of
them that higher education is now beyond
saving there's just no way you can save
it and the only alternative is to build
other
other colleges do you agree with that or
do you think we can still save this
particular system i think you'd i think
you need massive reforms i i think that
um
so i run a non-profit and
i would never get a donation if i had
the kind of overhead that most of these
schools have and overhead defined as
administrators and fundraisers um
because if you look at the budget of of
harvard of of of any of these schools
you know by different calculations they
have like 80 85 percent overhead um a
massive bureaucratization of
universities um should at least be tried
um
in my opinion partially because those
very same professors you know who came
on your on your on your show you know i
think i think of you know our advisor
steve pinker i think of my friend john
height i think of paul bloom
there are there is great research and
writing going on um in higher education
among some of the professors um and most
of the havoc comes from the
administrators that maybe um there would
some reforms could actually go a long
way to fix it that being said i don't
think there's going to be meaningful
reform in the yales and harvards and
princeton's as long as they think that
they are the only game in town to
getting your children into the gonna
sound like a marxist again ruling class
um and what's funny is that if i can
imagine so many different competing
systems that could actually tell because
i'm an employer as well that could tell
employers that um this is an incredibly
bright incredibly hard working person
and guess what because you generally if
someone went to an elite college in the
us you can
it's a more or less safe bet that they
are pretty smart and were pretty hard
working at least in high school um like
those but that's it you don't know if
they understand statistics you don't
know if they understand history you
don't know if they understand law you
don't know if they understand economics
any of these basic things so i think a
lot about if you could start promising
to some of these companies that care
about making a profit that there's this
alternative system that actually
identifies the best brightest hardest
working most creative people in the
country um that's when you start scaring
the yales and princeton's and um and
harvard's um and
only then do i think that they'll they
will start taking any meaningful action
to get their acting gear that's a really
interesting point greg and sticking with
education one of the things that people
uh on in this conversation often i've
heard at least said is that the next
generation so francis and i are like
geriatric millennials and then there is
the next generation whatever they're
called and then there's another
generation coming below them and the
idea was you know every action causes a
reaction the pendulum swings and this
new generation coming through oh they
love offensive humor and they hate
restrictions of speech and and they're
all about you know the stuff that we'd
all agree on is there any evidence for
this
um i've heard this assertion as well my
understanding is there is um there is
evidence in the polling that there is a
backlash effect going on
um i'll believe it when i see it you
know essentially um i do think my and my
big fear i wrote this 6 000 word article
for a reason um magazine
uh talk and i call it the
the second great age of political
correctness and my whole point there is
like i was saying earlier that that um
uh that this is exactly what happened
last time in in the late 90s is it can't
we can't continue to have this kind of
you know for lack of a better term
cancel culture
go on at its current rate forever
because eventually literally run out of
people or at least people brave enough
to uh uh to descend so there will
absolutely have to be a turning back of
the pendulum to some degree and arguably
that's already happening to at least
some some modest degree
um but if we think that oh thank
goodness that's over because we lost our
minds for a couple of years there um
that doesn't fix the problem it still
means that you have institutions that
have no viewpoint diversity they um that
they are a wildly over bureaucratized
all of these problems haven't actually
been fixed so i think that relying on
the pendulum to swing back is not
sufficient even if it does swing back
and we shouldn't assume just like you
like you're skeptically pointing out
that it necessarily will
and greg why is it and i've got my own
theories
on this that
the institutions most pro most prone to
this always tend to be the wealthiest
always tend to be the most you know
prestigious always tend to be the most
privileged
i i find it fascinating what do you
think that is
uh rob henderson coined the term i
believe it was him um he's a a amazing
thinker um and way younger than he's
coming on the show very soon so we'll
ask him if it's a quote of his go ahead
oh terrific luxury beliefs um that
essentially um
there's a class of belief that you can
have that it
improves you in esteem among people from
your class um that has no harm to you
but makes you seem more pure more moral
more upstanding but actually harms uh
other people in this in the society and
definitely i saw a lot of luxury beliefs
in my sort of journey up the class
ladder
in the united states it was it could be
um i remember in my human rights classes
in uh when i was at stanford it was
i realized that the theme seemed to be
um and i was always pointing this out so
they hated me for it but it seemed to be
that the professor's idea of what the
good should look like was more important
than helping actual people
survive in many cases in the real world
and i was constantly like hey that
sounds like you're just being
puritanical about it has to be your way
or the highway and you're literally
willing to kill people over that so i
think that there is
unfortunately in the united states we
still have an idea that sort of like
you know lenin
and mao and che guevara are people to be
people to be celebrated when that's
utterly offensive to the to the rest of
the united states but is this idea of
this uncompromising person of the people
kind of thing and i do think that never
correcting that way of thinking about
the world um you know leads to even
deeper problems a
re-romanticization of the old soviet
union for example which i thought was
that the fact that the new york times
did in 2018
did a entire like year-long thing
talking about uh the [ __ ] revolution
including articles that talked about how
sex was better during during the soviets
i'm like this this is unbelievable to me
like this is this is a monstrous you
know like i like that lie so we never
fix so basically what i'm saying here is
we never fixed the old problems that the
ruling elite the united states had
um and we're doing very little to to to
to fix the new ones but it is pretty
normal unfortunately for
upper class people to just think of
themselves as to rationalize their
belief that they're better than
everybody else they just do it now in a
way that seems very self-flagellating
but it's really about those other rubes
over there
well greg it's been an absolutely
fascinating conversation thank you so
much for joining us we're about to ask
you a couple of questions from our
supporters that only they will get to
see on our local community but before we
do that uh we always have uh one final
question which is always the same what
is the one thing we're not talking about
as a society that we really should be
um i think it's about major reform to
american higher education
um i mean i i said it it it it's one of
the things i really hit all all
throughout i think when
um some of the bills you know that are
being passed the united states
particularly as they apply to higher
education they're going after viewpoints
which is not okay like you you can't in
the us under the first amendment nor
should you be able to go after
professors because of their viewpoint or
books because of their viewpoint but i
do think that the insane
hyper-prioritization of universities is
a scandal i do think that that in a lot
of these cases like the like the
situation where the yale uh law school
students shouted down what was supposed
to be sort of a kumbaya session between
conservative uh supreme court lawyers
and liberal supreme court lawyers um the
the scandal there in particular is not
just that a hundred students in a class
of 180 showed up to shout it down it's
that it was encouraged by administrators
and those administrators are still
employed by yale so i think that
figuring out who the bad like the fact
we're not even firing the administrators
who are causing this problem the first
place is something that everybody should
be thinking about this doesn't even seem
to be on the radar
greg it's been an absolute pleasure that
uh the time has flown by if people want
to find you online greg where is the
best place to do that where is the best
place to look for your books where's the
best place to find out about fire uh
thefire.org um we have a lot of great
content coming out we have um we
actually have a surprisingly good tick
tock game um you know
my if you can spell my last name you can
find my books um you know pretty easily
but definitely check out thefire.org
we're doing a lot of public education at
the moment on freedom of speech as a not
just a legal value but as a as a moral
and philosophical value as well
greg thank you so much for coming on
we'll do the last couple of questions
for our locals in the second but in the
meantime thank you for being on the show
and thank you all for watching and
listening we'll see you very soon with
another brilliant episode like this one
or raw show all of them go out at 7pm uk
time and for those of you who like your
trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
the best treatment for anxiety and
depression among young people is
cognitive behavioral therapy for their
parents